which of the ordered pairs is a solution
of the following equation
negative 3x minus y is equal to 6.
what we have to remind ourselves is when
we're given an ordered pair the first
number is the x coordinate and the
second number is the y coordinate or the
y value so when they tell us the ordered
pair negative 4 comma 4 they're saying
hey look if x is equal to negative 4
and y is equal to positive 4 does that
satisfy this equation and what we can do
is we can just try that out so we have
negative 3
and everywhere where we see an x
everywhere we see an x we can replace it
with negative 4. so it's negative 3
times negative 4
minus
minus and everywhere we see
and everywhere we see a
and everywhere we see a y we can replace
it with positive 4
we replace it with positive 4. so
negative 3 times x
minus
y which is 4
needs to be equal to 6
needs to be equal to 6. now is this
indeed the case negative 3 times
negative 4
is positive 12
positive 12 minus 4
positive 12 minus 4 is equal to 8 it's
not equal to 6
is not equal is not equal to 6. so this
one does not work out
so let's see negative 3 comma 3. so we
can do the same thing here
let's see what happens when x is equal
to negative 3 and y
is equal to positive three
so we substitute back in we get negative
three
negative three
times x
which now we're going to try out x being
equal to negative three
minus y
y is positive 3 here
minus y let me do that y color that blue
minus y
now needs to be equal to
now it needs to be equal well just like
before it needs to be equal to six
so negative three times negative three
that's going to be positive nine
nine minus three is indeed equal to six
nine minus three
is indeed equal to six nine minus three
is six that is equal to six this works
out
so negative three comma three is
an ordered pair that is a solution to
this equation